all right so let's get to it we've got
some topics that we want to discuss and
obviously the first one is a direct
byproduct of our new reality to which we
are adjusting and as we enter into that
new reality next week starting Monday
currently technically officially the
NFL's legal tampering period opens at
noon eastern on Monday that's really
when free agency starts yeah it
officially begins Wednesday afternoon
but I know from last year it's gotten to
the point where they don't make any
pretense about it we'll know within
minutes who has agreed to terms where
last year it was Trent Brown like three
minutes out of the gates agreeing to
terms with the Raiders and that's the
way it is now if it goes forward and MDS
I've seen multiple reports no plans to
change the start of the league year no
plans to the Lavery agency and the media
is just pushing this blindly I look I'll
self-report to at old takes exposed
right now there's no way in hell free
agency is starting next week there is no
way they can allow the optics of all of
these guys signing multi-million dollar
contracts at a time where millions of
Americans are trying to come to terms
with maybe not having any income at all
for an extended period of time
significantly altering their daily
routine worrying about how this virus is
going to spread it would be the biggest
PR mistake for the NFL since playing
games two days after John Kennedy was
shot if they go forward with free agency
next week well one of the things that
we're seeing here is how rapidly this
story evolves and you know Mike this
week we first heard the NCAA tournament
will be played in empty arenas and at
the time we heard that we thought wow
the NCAA just took a really proactive
step more so than other sports has less
than 24 hours later it had turned into
what in the world is the NCAA doing
having these games at all
why haven't they canceled the entire
tournament yet and then very quickly
they did once that groundswell started
so you just it almost seems silly to
talk
in advance about well what is going to
happen next because we have seen how
quickly these things change you know to
the point where I think it was the Big
East tournament they called it off at
halftime of the first game the NBA we've
seen players pulled off the floor as
they were about to start a game this is
happening so quickly that I won't
believe it's the start of the league
year until it's the start of the league
year regardless of what they're saying
now because everything is changing so
fast as we try to wrap our arms around
this global pandemic yeah and the clue
is hiding in plain sight when the NFL
says no plans to delay the start of free
agency that means that the plans can and
will change and it's just unfortunate
that so many people in the media will
just push that because there are people
who believe it hey free agency next week
let's go I was on radio with Joe Rose in
Miami a little while ago and he was like
all right hey we're gonna have free
agency next week it's like Joe it ain't
happenin next week it's not happening
and you know there's a deeper issue here
where I think the NFL has blown an
opportunity to lead at a time when and
I'm gonna straight orde the third rail
of talking about politics but I think
most of us would agree that we are
suffering from a dearth of leadership
from our governmental entities right now
especially at the federal level all the
way up to the top and we've relied upon
our private institutions to step in and
provide the leadership and in the sports
world all of them did except the NFL and
I don't want to hear oh it's really not
our football season so we didn't have to
move look the NFL benefits from it being
football season all year long there's
playing season there's non playing
season the NFL is always front and
center and you know I I wish in
hindsight we had seen Roger Goodell on
NFL Network or somewhere else making a
clear strong statement that this is a
serious problem and we have events in
the offseason and we are as a right now
pulling the plug on everything
reassessing and then we'll let you know
as time passes what we are going to do
and I understand that if they're going
to continue with the draft for example
going to talk about that coming up they
have plans they need to follow through
on but
I just think that MDS to the extent that
people have not yet taken this seriously
and I'd like to think that the NBA
suspending its season was the moment
that people did take it seriously when I
see a full Pepsi Center last night in
Denver for a post Malone concert I
wonder what the hell those people are
paying attention to other than the fact
that well we bought the tickets let's go
to the show I mean are they not
listening are they not taking it
seriously and I feel like every major
institution in our country should be at
the forefront of getting people's
attentions and in that regard the NFL
had an opportunity and it either
negligently or intentionally squandered
it yeah I I actually thought there was a
time just a few days ago when the NFL
would come out and just say effective
immediately and until further notice no
one is getting on a plane for any
official NFL business not to go Scout
players not to bring players into your
facility have to go to pro days not for
free agent visits we're just not doing
it because we recognize the severity of
the situation we're facing and the NFL
has have done that the statements from
teams have just come in in dribs and
drabs a team will sail we're pulling our
scouts this team will say we're pulling
our coaches but not our scouts this team
will say we're letting our staff work
from home it should have just been a
league wide policy that a until we have
a better sense of what this situation it
is and how soon we can get it under
control
it's just gonna be a league wide policy
no travel for any type of league
business and I I was surprised I thought
we'd hear it like Monday and the NFL
would be leading the way now it's Friday
and whatever the NFL does next they'll
be well behind Major League Baseball the
NBA Major League Soccer the NHL the
English Premier League all the other
sports organizations and especially the
NCAA have taken significant steps that
the NFL for some reason is holding off
on taking and Sherine Williams and I
talked about this earlier damn PFT live
for me the canary in the coal mine was
the
meetings because it's been obvious for a
week now there was no way they were
gonna gather 32 owners many of whom are
in the high-risk category for a negative
outcome the ultimate negative outcome
from kovat 19a ka the coronavirus with
media and everything in a social setting
is just wasn't gonna happen it's not
gonna happen
why are they waiting to announce that
it's not gonna happen what in the world
is going on and it just tells me that
they've made the conscious decision or
the the unconscious decision to just
wait as long as possible to act and it
is a squandered opportunity to lead and
right now free agency it isn't happening
next week and I hope I'm right because
if I'm wrong and it happens it's it's
gonna cause me to view the NFL far
differently than I view the NFL right
now cuz it should not happen this is not
the time for multi-million dollar deals
to be done and hey the facilities are
all closed right if I'm a guy who's
going out as an owner of a team and
spending all this money on a free agent
I want to get the full benefit of that
contract which includes bringing the guy
to town having the press conference
holding up the Jersey and making it a
big deal and if we can just wait a few
weeks and do it later then wait a few
weeks and do it later they delayed free
agency MDS nine years ago until August
all because of what was a fairly
ordinary labor dispute well these are
extraordinary times they can bump back
free agency they should and I think they
will my understanding is they want to
see what happens with the CBA vote their
concern is if they announce it now the
CBA vote will will in turn be delayed
that and maybe they come out of this
with a buffer because as of right now
there's not much of a buffer between the
CBA vote figuring out what rules are
going to apply franchise tag deadlines
start a free agency so wait until after
the CBA vote and on Sunday say we're
gonna press pause on free agency I hope
that's what happens there's a strategic
reason for it but I think the broader
practical importance of making sure
people understand how serious this is
that's been squandered that's been blown
others have stepped in and provided the
leadership there
and the NFL didn't and and that's the
thing that upsets me the most yeah and
what you mentioned about players
traveling to their new city after they
sign that simply cannot happen in the
current environment and that is a big
part of why free agency has become such
a big part of the NFL year is that fans
get so excited when the signing happens
and the player comes to town and you
know the the big free agent signing is
usually invited to throw out the first
pitch at a local baseball team oh wait
that's not going to be happening because
baseball's shut down until at least two
weeks later than they were originally
planning and maybe much longer than that
you know there's a whole rigmarole that
happens after a free agent signs and it
simply cannot happen this year and I
don't think the NFL can really I I don't
I don't know how they're gonna gonna cut
the baby in half so that they have just
the right end of what we can do free
agency but we can't do any of the travel
associated with free agency any of the
events where we invite our season
tickets to come ticket holders to come
to a rally where our big free agent
signing has just come you know the think
if think of the Chargers were to sign
Tom Brady and they would want to have
some huge event in Los Angeles where
they're saying hey you didn't think we
could sell tickets before we're selling
tickets now and they want to draw mobs
of fans too whatever that event is that
ain't happening anytime soon
yeah and that's all the more reason to
press pause on free agency and if need
be press pause on the draft
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports